imaginez
être sur une plage méditer pour
réfléchir pendant le temps de pratiquer
de la tension le cercle d'élèves de cm2
semble se calmer certains se prêtent au
jeu d'autres sourient aux ris mais une
chose est sûre lorsque la question
philosophique du jour est posée les
idées fusent aujourd'hui ce sera qu'est
ce qu'une vie réussie sa vie c'est
d'avoir fait des bonnes actions avoir
rempli des objets utiles au voyage
voyelles et parce qu'elle sent qu'on
pense c'est que veulent aux parents une
douzaine avoir une bonne famille qui ont
confiance en nous on essaie de les aider
à réfléchir à penser par eux-mêmes à
approfondir leur réflexion a interrogé
peut-être remettre en cause leurs
certitudes penser par soi-même ou encore
développer son esprit critique ces
ateliers de philosophie dispensés 12
fois dans l'année aborde plusieurs
thèmes la violence le regard de l'autre
ou encore le bonheur c'est quoi votre
style en dessous pourquoi parce qu'on
devait réfléchir à quelle était la
violence l'abus légitimes et illégitimes
j'étais donc ça nous a fait réfléchir on
estime que l'enfant tout petit déjà se
pose des questions même des questions
existentielles c'est quoi la mort c'est
quoi la vie pourquoi j'existe et se
posent des questions tout petit essai
pour les habitués justement à réfléchir
dès le plus jeune âge j'aime bien parler
en calmer de biens sécurité ça évite les
disputes des fois dans la cour un peu et
les christs philosophique dont c'est dur
de yahia pas de bonne réponse aux
panneaux verts des ateliers apprécié des
enfants qui leur permettent d'élaborer
une vraie réflexion de résister aux
manipulations ou encore de chasser les
préjugés l'atelier philosophique c'est
aussi une forme de prise de parole
l'expression l'apprentissage de la prise
de paroles l'apprentissage aussi du
raisonnement ce qui est important pour
pour nos enfants j'aime bien réfléchir
et écouter les réponses des autres par
exemple tout à l'heure j'ai appris la
vraie définition du mot heureux alors
que moi je pensais c'était juste être
content ça nous apprend déjà les
définitions ça nous apprend à pas
forcément faire tout ce qu'on te dit ça
nous apprend à réfléchir et pas c'est
pas parce que quelqu'un dit quelque
chose que nous on doit penser pareil des
ateliers qui semble avoir que des
retours positifs pour ces enfants qui ne
se prive pas de poursuivre les débats le
soir en famille ou dans la cour de
récréation